first on CBS this morning the daughter
of a man killed by gunmen allegedly
targeting black people in a supermarket
is talking about her legal fight that
she hopes will change gun policy the
gunman killed two people in a Louisville
area Kroger last October now it's legal
for people to carry guns in Kentucky and
Kroger does not look block rather its
customers from taking firearms inside
the stores CBS this morning national
correspondent Jericka Duncan continues
her reporting on gun violence she spoke
with a woman who's on a mission now to
keep guns out of the stores jurika what
she's saying
well Kelly Watson is now suing Kroger
after her father's murder she hopes that
Kroger will ban guns from its stores
while some businesses have gun bans in
place others especially in open carry
states like Kentucky do allow weapons
inside but Watson says she believes
stores won't be safe for everyone unless
that changes it was unbelievable to hear
the fear and panic in his voice Kelli
Watson says she was just finishing her
workday last October when she received a
phone call from her 12 year old son What
did he say that his grandfather was shot
Watson's father 69 year old Maurice
Stallard had been shopping for school
supplies with her son at a Louisville
Kentucky Kroger when a gunman opened
fire killing two people including
Stallard what do you think stop the
alleged gunman from shooting your son
because he ran that's it Watson's son
survived he hadn't run out I would not
have my son on my father right now
Gregory Allen Busch was indicted by a
federal grand jury for hate crimes this
October a judge will determine if Bush
is mentally competent to stand trial to
think that this man is loving and as
caring as he was to have been taken from
us in the way that he was taken because
of someone else's hate it's unbelievable
that comes last week Watson and her
mother Charlotte Stallard filed a civil
lawsuit against Kroger who would have
known that Kroger are allowed people to
just walk in and carry weight their guns
on their waistband and pull them out
right now Kroger does not have a policy
prohibiting customers from bringing
firearms into their stores the company
released a statement on its website
stating their long-standing policy on
the issue is to follow state and local
gun laws and asking customers to be
respectful of others while shopping you
don't need a gun to buy groceries Ron
Johnson is the Stallard family's
attorney you can't carry a gun into your
school you can't carry a gun into the
courthouse and what we're simply saying
is grocery stores need to do the same
thing
the lawsuit details more than two dozen
gun related incidents resulting in eight
deaths inside and outside of Kroger
stores nationwide the duty of a store in
Kentucky is to provide a safe place to
shop that is the law so retailers like
Target and Starbucks have said having
guns in our stores is not consistent
with having a safe place to shop so they
don't allow guns can a judge force
someone or an entity like Kroger to
change its policy all a judge or a jury
can do is give damages to those who are
harmed when Kroger doesn't meet its duty
Watson says she hopes her lawsuit will
help make public spaces safer as this
continues to occur not just at a Kroger
but at a Walmart or at a church it is
traumatic it is violent it is dramatic
it is painful we have to do something to
try to prevent these things from
happening again to us a spokesperson
from Kroger told us they do not comment
on pending litigation but they extended
their deepest sympathies to the families
impacted by this senseless violence
because there was also another woman
involved in this Nicki Lee Jones she
actually recently filed a civil suit as
well I remember we covered this story
didn't get a lot of the coverage that we
see on the other shootings but it shows
you that behind these stories there are
real people that are still in a lot of
pain you can't help but yes remember
what that attorney said you don't need a
gun to buy groceries yeah you really
feel for this family and that is true
you do not need a gun to buy your
groceries Trika thank you very much
thank you